hey
oh welcome to fat baby odd man i'm kevin
smith
i am mark bernardin and hey
here we are uh socially from home as
uh you know we've heard right now is all
terrible and the spirit of
nobody be able to go anywhere for
thanksgiving to be with their family
we figured we would do this socially
distance this week as well
and no reason for us to have fun when
nobody else can have fun
can't rub it in by being in the same
room with people and [ __ ] how you been
uh i'm doing all right man i'm doing all
right i i thought of you quite a bit
this week
of course i mean always um i did my
first
fast this week how many how long did you
go
i did 24 hours what the [ __ ] on and
how'd you feel
um i you know as you say every time
it's not as bad as you think it's going
to be you know provided you
do the you start the clock if the clock
is on your side if you go from like
dinner to dinner
then like oh all right you know i'm
sleeping for a third of this actually
then it becomes like eating a meal a day
right like when you do that um it is
surprisingly
kind of simple and you're right to time
it out that way
it's pretty damn good but there's a
feeling i like to
get up in the morning uh not having
eaten that's my favorite part of the
fast where i'm like
[ __ ] i made it through a [ __ ] day
like without eating that's when i that's
when it like [ __ ] juices me up so for
the first 24 hours
i i do find it like difficult let's make
or break
where you're like uh all right am i
really gonna do this and stuff and if
you've got a busy day
it's easy it's just easy to forget
eating and stuff
it's been challenging during quarantine
because
every day is like more or less empty
other than a few things here
um but how'd you feel after it um
you know i i it's funny like i felt a
little bit
like lightheaded isn't the thing you
know that that weird like low blood
sugar
jitters isn't the thing uh i felt hollow
because i had no food in me um
but i i felt pretty good you know and i
think that the goodness was more
um uh a reward for proving i had the
will to do it
less than it was a real physical
response to
to the lack of caloric intake it was
just like yeah buddy you did that
just you feel pretty good that's one of
the things i like most about it is
knowing that i have
discipline enough to be like i can i can
master
myself i can master my appetites because
when
you gorge you feel the opposite of that
where you're like oh my god i'm [ __ ]
i can't control myself
so when you go into that fasting mode it
gives me a sense of like no
i'm i'm i'm disciplined i can do this
you know yeah
especially because you know of of all of
the things in my life
that i can exert control over um
food has traditionally been the most
difficult
and like oh yeah i can i can work if you
tell me i got a
deadline i'll hit the deadline if you
get to tell me i gotta go and you know
do dad [ __ ] i can go do that like
anything else seems to be thoroughly and
totally doable
um except for my relationship with food
so to spend that 24 hours not giving in
to the siren song of
deep fried or even steamed
anything um yeah that was nice
it's it's it's cool to know you can do a
thing
yes we're like check me out i had no
idea and stuff
um good for you um all the things yeah
new things are always worth [ __ ]
trying
new things are always yeah it felt a bit
like
that feeling when you finish your first
screenplay slash tv pilot slash comic
book that like the first time you did it
like i almost don't care if this is good
or not i'm just happy i did it
yeah because there's a decent chunk of
people who will never do this
very true completion um sometimes one of
the most important parts of the deal
i believed this week um
this is certainly not a i guess it will
be something of a commercial in as much
as
it's something you can buy but no
letter came with it no love you know hey
this is your
directive or anything like that i think
it's meant to be a gift
but they gave me a couple of them so you
know i don't know maybe
hand them out to jason and stuff this
that comes from it's milestone star wars
gentle giant
and diamonds collect toys um
and uh box lunch you know the box lunch
people
mm-hmm so they're related to like um
uh a hot topic and
uh kind of the higher end hot topic
where pricier items but
whatever you buy they give a little
money to to charity as well um
this is the uh
the box lodge milestones
uh gentle giant diamond select toys
the child i'm assuming a sculpture
not a toy the other episode i busted up
yeah this is
1928 of 5 000.
so it's a limited edition little statue
limited edition number
statue all right let's see what he looks
like remember when
um the show came out last year
and there was no baby yoda nothing
yeah the only piece of merch that i saw
was not it was all like
kind of custom empty a lot of etsy stuff
yeah um they have
more than made up for that now there's
[ __ ] baby yoda
everything at this point and this
is a sculpture in the greater shirt
um
we also next week
marvel is sending us a book
to uh talk about on the show
they got a service over at marvel
uh sounds like essentially like their
version of the
um absolute editions over at dc
where they've put together like fat ass
gigantic
versions of the book and it's only made
to order
like wow they don't mass produce it
only do a certain percentage and it's
curated
so they wanted to send over a book to
show us what it looked like and i said
[ __ ] yeah
do it couldn't get here in time so we'll
do it next week
god damn it here we go
things are feeding me mark
you can do it
you know there it is damn it man
big pet peeve of mine things that are
[ __ ] way too packaged
oh but this is nice it's a very oh it's
adorable
no he got his little cup and sipping the
tea
this is what it looks like
that is super cute i sip in my tee and
uh
gorgeous ah not too heavy
uh this is uh like i said 1928 of
5 000. they've only made five votes
so if they sent it to me to showcase on
the show mission accomplished but
yeah if not bonus for you sideshow right
i just got me a free statue
and stuff look at him look at him oh
who's your cutest little child
um how awesome yeah speaking of
mandalorian
this is something i put it up on social
media a while back but when i went to
the star
wars premiere the last one um
the rise of skywalker um
john favreau was there and i was just
like oh my god and i hadn't seen
mandalorian yet but i was like holy crap
man like congratulations blowing up and
[ __ ]
i said uh who created baby yoda and he
was like i did
and i was like he goes i wrote
everything i said i didn't know that
so he gave me uh a what do they call
them um
challenge coin this is the mandalorian
challenge coin man this is
okay it says mandalorian and then does
it say this is the way
uh it doesn't say it in english but if i
had to guess whatever language that is
probably says this is the way
and then on the back ah
says that an executive producer
cert stuff so do they have challenge
coins for every member of the cast like
this
one like i got to imagine like or crew
at least that there's a bunch of
different
challenge coins collect them all you
know [ __ ] you got yourself the
favorite one
the polonie matching favreau filoni
would become yeah
i mean if it'll let me play a game of
contra then i'm down you ain't kidding
i was wondering i'm like did he like do
i
he gave it to me i was like oh this
rocks and it sat like on my bathroom
sink for a long time
but i was like maybe i'm supposed to
like hand this in
for some best car seal or for a job
where i'm like
[ __ ] hand this in he goes now you get
to direct an episode
ah then i would take it back because i
was like that sounds like a lot of work
but can i be can i use my challenge coin
to be in the episode because that would
rock
being in an episode of the mandalorian
one of the most watched [ __ ] things
in the world right now
i mean you know they're they're putting
a bunch of people in there like you know
horatio sans gets to be in there
[ __ ] and they're twice just slather
me up with some makeup
i'm down people ask me like oh my god
don't you want to direct that and like
not as much as i want to be in it
i mean look i guess i could do both if i
was directing it that i could cast
myself in a thing but like
that sounds like a lot of work i'd
rather i'm just not visionary enough
uh but i am visionary enough to be in it
and [ __ ] and then i thought what if they
were like
all right you could be in it but you
definitely have to take your shirt off
you're like at the price being in the
mandalorian you got to show your
titties and i'm like and then it's the
[ __ ] flash dance scene
no it's fantastic fame i would be crying
man i would i wouldn't do
i couldn't go full cocoa
[Laughter]
that's a different thing in a pixar
world i don't want to go full cocoa you
mean sad and about the day of the dead
no no take your top off it's when you're
in like this
dank new york apartment and some guy
with a
low end video camera tells you the
director
yes i need you to look at my
vulnerability
something that apparently haunted our
entire generation because everyone our
age
you've dropped that reference people
like oh damn
yeah no nobody wants their cocoa moment
no that that that that's the end of a
bunch of bad decisions
uh she walked away on skate thank god
yes
i've also spent a decent chunk of this
week playing uh the spider-man miles
morales game
uh how is that i saw maddie cohen on
twitter
talked about he played it and took him
like five six hours to beat it he said
he loved
every second of it yeah it's uh it's
it's pretty great
i uh i full-on rolled a couple of tears
at the end of it
because they a i mean it ends with you
know heroic sacrifice and all that stuff
and
but it has a really nice kind of nod to
the
spider-man 2 scene on the subway train
where it's like you know a bunch of
people and there's spider-man
like he's just a he's just a kid he's
just a kid
you know and then to see that pivoted
and kind of remixed and refashioned for
for the miles morales game was pretty
great and the the gamer itself is just
so much fun to play i don't know if
you've
had a chance but it's the closest you
get to swinging through
manhattan um as spider-man like the the
mechanics are so great and the feel of
it is so great
and i could just do that all day like
you know some people
want to watch you know whatever leaves
fall and apple screensavers i could just
swing through manhattan
the the wind in my hair the place to go
nope
what's that oh hey there's an
adventurous tower in the game for a long
time without having to
face a [ __ ] gangster or something
yeah
you could literally just [ __ ] tool
around um for as long as you want to
play the game did you pull the cat out
of the bag spider cat or whatever the
[ __ ]
i haven't gotten there yet that's that's
i finished the game i finished the main
storyline
but you know then there's other missions
you could do and one of them is
spider-man is the name of the cat um
wants to be your friend
and so that's where i'm off to next i'm
off to be friends with a cat
i'm wondering if uh is twitter down
i'm trying to get to it on my laptop but
it ain't working but and maybe it's i
thought
huh i was trying to grab some comments
but it's not coming up on my laptop
um did you do something bad did they
take your twitter away kevin
i did they're marking all my tweets like
[ __ ] specious
this [ __ ] needs to be checked in
and the tweet is disputed by the
election authorities when i'm like
was awesome they're like this tweet is
the dispute
all right shall we uh dive into the news
we can dive into the news man um because
we got
you know there was some very big news
that broke a couple of days ago that we
remember
those at home we we had a [ __ ] uh uh
summit texting summit
uh when this news broke to see if we
should do an emergency show
but it's big news but it seems to have
like
been lost in a sea of bigger news over
the last few days
so we might as well put our spin on it
tell them what it is
um you know we have been surmising for
months if not
half a full year when we would get to
see certain movies and you know we've
been commenting periodically on shifts
in the release counter
and and all of that stuff and one of the
last big movies that was kind of a
holdout was wonder woman 84 had
until very recently been
just set to open on christmas day in
theaters
for all of the reasons because you know
they spent a boatload on it
um it would be a good enticement to get
people back out to
to to go to theaters and to help kind of
rejuvenate the entire
exhibition industry which is oh hey
um but the the
the shoe has fallen and wonder woman
1984
will drop on hbo max on christmas day
huge news that like a few months ago we
were all like that'll never happen
now we live in that world where it looks
like it's pasta distinct
well it's happening probably yes um
it's free if you subscribe to hbo max
they're not hitting you for any
additional money
unlike they were very very quick to
point that out
like in all their ads so as not to be
confused with the mulan approach which
is
you've got the app but you have to pay
on top of the app so these cats have
been saying like no way
like if you got the app already you're
getting it it's happening
right or if you subscribe which is even
more what they're hoping for
um because you know at the end of the
day whatever money they would have made
theatrically
which who knows what that is given the
the the fact that
covid is on the rise in the us it's on
the rise overseas the theatrical
businesses of shambles
um so there's no way to know who would
have been able to see it on christmas
day
uh let alone pushing it deeper into next
year where everything becomes a lot of
gym there's already
50 or 60 big releases that have been
pushed into next year
to find room along with the other 200
releases that were already coming out in
2021.
um so yeah they they decided that they
would use this
ultimately as a a good thing for the
fans
b and encouragement to stay home and
don't go to the theater because the
thing you were going to go out for
is in your house so maybe don't go
and see to aggressively inject some some
enthusiasm for hbo max as a screen as a
streaming service
the money that uh you know they would
have made at the box office had there
been no covid
easily a billion dollars easily yeah
um you know they were looking at a
covered reality and realizing that like
you know tenant didn't bring them out
and even if they did triple the business
tenant did
it's not worth the effort like it costs
a lot to market a movie and get it into
theaters and stuff like that
on top of the costs you've already spent
making it
whereas you could and also like you want
to get that movie off your books for the
year
like you don't want to create another
year it's like easily a 200 million
dollar movie or more
so in a world where it's you're stuck
between a rock and a hard place
like you weigh a certainly against an
hour and you doubt that you could do
that well at a box office but you're
pretty certain that you'll pick up
subscriptions yeah [ __ ] debuting this
movie
you know on hbo max and stuff um it
could be a pivotal moment in history
where we all look back this could be
jaws
where oh we all look back like and
that's when it all
[ __ ] um i do believe
i know everyone's like theaters are
gonna they're dying and
we all know that they are i you know i
think
it's gonna be until next year until like
the vaccine is out there in the world
and everyone
feels safe again that you could even
think about
getting the movie business going in the
way that they can make money off of it
the way they did in the past
so they were going to have to wait until
summer
2021 and there's still no guarantee that
come summer 2021
we will no longer be in this 12 monkeys
existence of ours and [ __ ]
so tough [ __ ] call man but like in a
world where
what it seems like warner brothers is
like going
all in on hbo max going like this is the
future
so like direct consumer this is what
we're all about
i mean number one i'm happy because i
get to watch it at home and i i tweeted
that and then some people were like you
should be wanting to see this in the
theater and i'm like
there's a lot of things i want to do
you can't do them anymore well we can't
do them anymore
i look forward to watching this [ __ ]
flick like on at home and you know
i'm not bragging but i do have a pretty
large television so
it will be like watching it in the
theater for me more or less
yeah but it's it's i i never would have
bet on this moment
now i can't imagine
there's not some disney black widow
announcement coming down the pike pretty
soon
you know there there very well could be
you know there very well could be
because i think that
i mean disney's in a slightly different
position and then when they launched
disney plus
the the disney plus they they did it
very well
they had everything that people wanted
and within
whatever four months of launch they
released hamilton
which turned into this like that for
them was their wonder woman
in a way which was this was going to be
a theatrical release we know it's the
most popular thing on the planet
we're going to give it to you for free
if you subscribe to this platform and
we're also going to
do away with our pesky free seven-day
trial which we know you're gonna sign up
for and watch out
and then cancel so no we're getting that
month out of you at least
and in a world in which the only thing
that
wall street has to judge whether or not
a media stock is
viable or not at this point is streaming
it's not
theatrical releases it's not parks it's
not you know cruises it's not really
merchandise it is literally
just streaming and and it is incredibly
important for
for hbo and warner media to goose the
numbers
on the hbo max launch because they
didn't launch as robustly
as as disney plus did and and you know
neither of them can compete really
they're
you know at best disney plus is about
half what netflix is
but hbo max is about a tenth and so they
they got
they got some ground to gain and this i
think for them
whatever money they leave on whatever
mythical table
um it's worth it if it brings them 10 20
30 million new subscribers to this
service
um i uh i'll be there
on christmas eve man
moment it turns december 25th i'll be
[ __ ]
watching because i've wanted to see
kristen wiig as cheetah for a long long
time
yeah but what a weird moment to be
standing in
you know gratifying for those of us who
you know like comic book movies i wanted
to see this flick
um you know uh
i'm not gonna call it troubling or
worrisome as a
as a filmmaker because it's not like i
make movies like that but
it you know this could be a pivotal
moment where if [ __ ] never goes back to
normal
this was the pass that allowed to kind
of like well
it worked and now you know
who's to stop anyone from doing like
disney's already putting up seoul
on his bus they've already done mulan
um i i saw an ad online
but you know um grace randolph
one of her tweets she called attention
to it because somebody
tweeted her and said do you see this and
it was a disney plus ad that could have
been made
could have been fan mail but it
indicated that april we were going to
get black widow
on disney plus so it looked like
well made the spot it looked like a bus
spot and it also talked about
doing a disney plus 18 or something like
that that's why people think the ad
is fake because like i think disney just
announced that it's called disney star
or something like that but they're going
to have a section on disney plus
with r-rated movies something that
heretofore they have
not talked about it right so um
if that ad is to be believed then it
could just be an incredibly well made
[ __ ] fake
um they're gonna be announcing something
soon and that announcement would be that
black widow is going to be
available at home and after wonder woman
i certainly wouldn't be surprised if
that was the case and and
i'd [ __ ] hungrily greedily watch that
too
and i'd pay that mulan premium on top of
yeah
i mean i think disney their mulan
experiment you know wasn't entirely
um successful but it also wasn't
entirely a failure either right and that
they still made
some you know 300 million dollars
selling mulan to an audience
without having to spend on distribution
without really having to spend on
advertising especially not billboards
anywhere because you're always driving
anywhere
but disney's very much it seems to be
about um
one cool thing a quarter you know where
it's like you got hamilton in july you
got something else in
the fall you get the mandalorian for
thanksgiving you'll get seoul for
christmas
you'll get one division in january so
maybe
you know and i'm not sure where falcon
and the winter soldier is gonna land but
it's entirely possible that that you
could absolutely get
a black widowish thing for easter or
memorial day or whatever but yeah
this is um something i've never done
before jc always gets to monitor
the chat oh are you muttering the child
i'm literally looking at the
the chat and i'm as you can see i'm
seeing myself
looking away and looking at the chat i
guess we're on a little bit of a delay
in case we say [ __ ] we're caught
let's see what people want to talk about
hello gentlemen
how are you tonight says paul stanley
the paul stanley
what don't you have something better to
do paul stanley
me and mark want to rock and roll all
night and party every day
uh let's see how ironic is it that we
can't see
wanda vision yeah what the [ __ ] did they
they moved wanda vision into 2021 yeah
january
yeah but i thought we were did they
initially announced that it was going to
be december
it was going to be december and then
they put seoul as their best that's
right we talked about this last week
yeah so there everything is just
shuffling back a little bit
um wow man look this is so crazy
watching in real time the show's gonna
come to a
screeching halt because i'm reading the
show
reaction to the show um
i mean i also think that there's there's
definitely going to be
when we get to go back to movie theaters
whatever that looks like because there's
going to be a handful
of chains that just go bankrupt like
because they just don't have money
and the government to date does not seem
to be interested in
in offering any kind of programs to help
um sustain
these giant movie change which the real
estate isn't alone
and to be fair like like i'm in the
movie business and stuff so naturally i
don't want to see him go away but like
a lot of things that the government
needs to be [ __ ] putting money into
and paying attention to
before movie theaters um
oh totally but you know while you're
bailing out everything
there is there's no reason not to to
include movie theaters as a thing to be
bailing out because
they can shake got a [ __ ] bunch of
money totally you know
i mean there's there there are still you
know tens of thousands of americans who
are employed by movie theaters across
the country
who no longer have an income um so
everything is hitting everybody so when
this is all done
i don't know what the cards look like
when they when they fall
no did you see that i mean joshua j
jackson says you look so healthy kevin
awesome job do i
i think i i honestly think i look fat
lately i'm kind of watching the show to
see how fat i look too
apparently josh is into you yeah well i
don't know if he's into me but he thinks
i look healthy and why thank you there
you go
i don't know if you're saying that the
way my wife is always like no you look
good
it's like like whenever she says that to
me
i think yeah but if you looked like i
looked
i wouldn't say that so
[Laughter]
and i and i know you're not kinder than
me so
i know you're just being you're lying
more um
no dj kento backs him up says i look
good wow
excellent you win nikki says i don't
look fat no you're out of your mind
kenneth ceres says the robe is slimming
i've always felt that
because it's a cloak we should all walk
around in ropes like dead eyes
like a scarlet pimper now [ __ ] yeah
badass man you know like i know
some people like like to wear less
clothes and [ __ ] like i was hiking
runyon
yesterday and some dude you know uh
was smoked past me as he's walking up
the hill he has way
faster gait than i do but then
[ __ ] like he's in a porn about
to [ __ ] somebody he just delivered a
pizza to
peels his [ __ ] shirt off man
and i sat there going like if i'd ever
been
thin in my life like if i'd
ever had a body that was tight
would i have ever been to take my shirt
off outside
kind of person and i don't think so i i
don't
i don't think i got an exhibitionist
streak in me and i don't think that dude
was like look at my [ __ ] mantids
but i just think i'm so like and i don't
know if it's based on who i've been my
whole life
but i think i'm so i'm too like buttoned
down when it comes to that to ever have
been that guy even if i was like ripped
right now
like if you see that picture of [ __ ]
chris hemsworth working out for
hulk hogan
i mean [ __ ] he's like you know it's a
joke about a cheat day he's like i'm
having a doughnut and he's doing one of
those [ __ ] lifting that
was like a human being could be that
[ __ ]
ripped and not worry like his arm
is gigantic bigger than it's been for
thor
he said that he has to get that big to
play hulk hogan
well he doesn't have to get that big but
he's choosing doing it
but what happens like i don't know
enough about working out like
if at a certain point if you don't keep
pumping that muscle up or keep it as big
as it
is does it just
go down or does it turn to flab or what
the [ __ ]
i mean it just it begins to atrophy
because you know
you're not feeding it like the way i
remember i had a friend
who was hugh jackman's personal chef and
uh when he lived in new york
and he was doing some broadway stuff it
was training and bulking up for
wolverine again
i was like yeah i have to deliver him
like whole
boiled chickens and steamed rice every
four hours
he's got to eat like 2 000 calories
every i got to wake him up to eat
because the amount that he's gotta work
out and the amount of sustenance that
body needs to maintain that level of
muscle is insane and so
yeah i mean chris hemsworth sure like
you can do that and you can you can keep
that for
brief periods nobody can be conan the
barbarian all the time
and then he just turns into a normal
person who can fit into his clothes
again
um it's not healthy to keep doing that
over and over and over again
and you can only really do it when
you're young because you know the
the drain and the strain on your heart
and your liver and your kidneys of
having to
process all of this food stuff
is not good but you know you're making
me feel better about being out of shape
keep telling me how [ __ ]
you'll live longer it turns out for
[ __ ]
young people and they're gonna be broken
with bad muscles and stuff i'm like all
right yeah keep that coming
yeah i got it yeah took my ears man yeah
jackman jackman went on record saying
like it's the worst way to live
training to be wolverine because there's
no joy
it's all work all the time i watched him
eat that [ __ ] meal man he was
uh what was he doing he was not
trying to bulk up he was getting
incredibly lean physically
fit for um that movie that was on hbo
uh bad education
um so he was he he talked about like i
have to lose
30 pounds because he played that guy
real like
tight that dude was in shape and stuff
like that
um but he had that meal i guess he was
like
four times a day but as we were sitting
there talking he had
[ __ ] steamed rice and chicken
so weird somebody said enter
excuse me god bless you nerdy energyment
said it just occurred to me that i've
literally never seen kevin's forearms
neither is my wife come on popeye
we have had sex on several occasions
every once in a while you see him like
got my wife's
name uh tattooed on one and my kid's
name
is tattooed on the other but they're
everything on me is like pale as a
[ __ ] belly of the fish and [ __ ] i
never seized the sun
yeah i i think that i too have lived
enough
of my life uh with some level of
body shame that even if tomorrow i was
granted some kind of magic [ __ ]
you know oscar isaac button that
suddenly turned me into that dude
i don't think i'm taking my shirt off
that much oscar isaac is your go-to
okay uh it's i remember seeing a picture
of him at some point and i was like
what does it feel like to be that
beautiful like in the world
like just walking around like what what
things do you get that other people
don't get like are they just bringing
you like [ __ ] bagels and ferraris
just because you look that way
i think they probably are and so
that had always been my imagine just
spending a day walking around looking
like that dude what happens to you
and that's a freaky friday movie
different world
you and me appreciate everything we got
in this life because we worked for it
so we don't know what it feels like
to just effortlessly like [ __ ]
collect
because you just you look
right yeah everybody like there's
universal
universal consensus i got a little
consensus in this house where my wife is
like i like the way you look i guess
enough that we've been married for two
decades but i'm talking universal
consensus
where like chris hemsworth or [ __ ]
oscar isaacs and you walk out there in
the world and man or woman everybody's
like i'd [ __ ] that guy
is the ideal that's the guy i want to
look like um
who was it this cat here said uh
level two trending trading says kevin
you lie to yourself you would
take off my shirt in public i don't
think i would man
like honestly it's like i've just never
been that
exhibitionist person i'm also not the
guy that like takes his dick out
like which you're not supposed to good
um
yeah i'm looking for credit and i'm like
i ain't one of those guys
what i'm talking about in front of other
guys and [ __ ] did you shower often in
high school
uh i mean every day you did it like you
they made you guys and then you actually
[ __ ] took the shower i i
i did well no i showered every day at
home
but yeah uh when i was when i played
football
i would shower yeah i would show after
games
but not after practices practices i
would just like to [ __ ] go home dirty
group shower with a bunch of naked boys
in it and [ __ ] yeah it was exactly like
starship troopers
basically was it really yeah just
everybody's just [ __ ] grab-assing
one of one of the most terrifying scenes
in cinema history to me is that shower
scene
in archer cooper's because it's it's
mixed gender
and they're all seen very comfortable
with each other being naked and [ __ ]
like that but in the real world
it's like if i walked in they'd all stop
talking and just start talking about
like look at it
and how do you live like that gotta
change and stuff like that but they
don't none of them say to each other in
that situation because they're all
impossibly pretty with tight bodies and
[ __ ] yes
they all got cast well um the amount of
[ __ ] times i showered in high school
man i could count on like one hand
after gym and [ __ ] like that they tried
to grade you every once in a while like
if you didn't take a shower
it took [ __ ] points off and i
remember on those days a quick run into
the bathroom and just throw water in my
hair
you know i'm clean yeah this is this
counts
i've been skinny my whole life and i
would not shower after football practice
or football games and i have a pool here
and i still wear like a rash guard when
i get in the pool here
so it's not it's not just you guys i'm
the same
i feel the same way so is yours a dick
thing or are you just like nobody needs
to see any of this i
it's more nobody needs to see any of
this but i think i'd be more comfortable
taking my dick out than taking my shirt
off
in a way wow you must have an incredible
[ __ ]
it's just something about the ex
such a high level of exposure
yeah i i appreciate how quickly this
podcast went off the rails
um that's loving it chad is taking it
like scary everybody's talking about
carrying it
up plug it up
most people in a generation like when
you think of showers
from from high school or showers from
movies i guess carrie is way up there
porky's also way up there um
which i know porkies was about the boys
looking in a girl's shower but like it
could go either way
they could so in that case like i don't
wanna i didn't wanna be in that shower
in the first place let alone being
[ __ ]
uh psycho shower scene of course pretty
horrifying
but at least only one person seeing you
right before they kill you
right it wasn't about like public
embarrassment unlike you know
the weird science shower scene which
just seemed to be existing
to embarrass wyatt and gary the one
where they're watching lisa take a
shower
um no there's an earlier one i think
earlier scene yeah where they like
pull their shorts out yeah because
they're in the shower wearing shorts
um all right man chuck and larry
shower scene says kevin lemke i don't
think i ever saw that
no i i skipped past i not pronounce you
chucking larry
pd club is asking are we sponsored by
manscape this week
just checking i know we're doing a lot
of talk about it
let's talk we're not but we do love the
good folks at
landscapes um speaking of show
i guess we should get off and
get to the business of that yeah what uh
what is going on in that entertainment
business other than uh
the wonder woman i live in the wonder
woman um
deadpool 3 uh seems to be proceeding
in that uh because there had been a
bunch of they weren't talking about it
for a minute there didn't seem to be a
plan but apparently they were
building a plan and now the plan is
being put into play
indeed you know and then and the big the
big movement there is not that
you know disney bought fox and so they
also got the rights to it but they
actually hired writers to work on a
deadpool 3.
um now are are the writers um
our buddies who wrote the last two um
so far no they are not um rhett reese
and paul wernick
um recent work such a great job yeah no
they did a fantastic job
um but apparently um wendy molyneux
and lizzie molyneux logan are writing
deadpool 3.
are those the sisters of
um that do uh bob's burgers
indeed bob's burgers in the great north
um and
i i i have found their work to be very
charming and very funny
um and so apparently ryan reynolds had
uh spent
you know the better part of the last
month meeting with a handful of writers
to hear their pitches and
they went for the mali news's um
how soon are we going to see something
like that um
you know not for a while um a
covid so who the hell knows and b you
know i don't know how deep into the
writing process they are
but it's it's it's a it's up for debate
um but it does seem as if disney at some
in some fashion is open to keeping
deadpool
rated r oh really yes
um which is which is exciting especially
given that it's the first
deadpool movie to come under directly
under kevin feige's control
um i think uh if he was smart and he is
he's
the smartest guy in the room it's just
like they're making money
let him do it just yeah go nuts
and now it's like they can make even
more money if they put a few other
marvel characters pop-up in deadpool as
well
yeah so that that i think is probably
the biggest question is how do you
meld the tones of deadpool in the mcu
if deadpool's going to still be r and
then can you have [ __ ]
you know star-lord sweep in probably but
it gets a little
one of them's got to work blue or one of
them
scene video archive says is tj miller
going to be in deadpool 3.
thoughts um i i
i mean it's it's way too early to be
able to to do anything but guess
but i've had to guess sure
you know i mean kind of me too and now
this is disney
he did get me tood and this is disney um
but
who knows i'm just saying it seems like
in a world where disney's going back to
it i'm sure they'd be like
yeah can you get your questionable
friends behind yeah i mean i guess it
depends on on a how long it takes for
this thing to actually
go before cameras and b if tj miller
undergoes some sort of public relations
rejuvenation that makes him less
radioactive
it's possible you know between now and
two years from now sure
quan is guessing he says i'm sure he's
going to get killed off screen
[Laughter]
entirely possible um elsewhere in the
disney universe
um there are going to be more predators
20th century studios has engaged the uh
director of attention i've been in
hollywood for 26 years there are always
predators and there's always gonna be
more predators mark this is not news
no but like space predators oh
the better one is the ones we'd rather
be accosted by
so they're making a predator movie yeah
you know who's making it dan
yes dan trachtenberg made uh
well he did i think he did the pilot of
the boys if i remember correctly
mm-hmm you're actually in cloverfield
lane uh but he did cloverfield lane
but well i always think and you know
dan's a wonderful filmmaker but what i
always think of dan traxberg guys
is my gateway to podcasting him
and his friend did a podcast called
drone
and they were like do you want to be on
our show when we had the old office
uh down on de longprey and so they came
over to the office with their like
portable
little gear thing and that was the first
podcast i was ever on and stuff and i
was so
charmed by the whole thing i was like
what like we just talk as long as we
want i could curse it don't matter and
they're like yeah you do whatever you
want
and i just had a [ __ ] blast with it
and stuff like that so
in that moment in time many years ago
we transferred souls and i took on the
soul of the podcaster and he
became the soul of a guy who did
important things film
um he's a good dude man i talked to him
like years later like last year or two
years ago for something i
i saw him and we were bullshitting um
good dude but uh so what it's this is
a predator they made a predator movie
not too long ago
with uh what's shane black yeah yeah
yeah yeah in 2018
um which is written and directed by
shane
it didn't do particularly well and it
also happened to be
why they're gonna double down and make
another one well i mean it's it's one of
those
we have this ip it can be good
the last time out was awful um does
anybody have a good take on it
and dan trachtenberg apparently had a
great take on it and
and uh the script is being written by a
fellow named patrick ayson
who i worked with on shredstone and is a
lovely dude super [ __ ] smart
and uh and is the perfect guy to do a
thing like this
l meant r elements wrote predator versus
quality
i mean look yeah in the hands of anybody
uh anything could be cool again
and stuff like that so i'm sure he'll
bring something to it and the predator
is still kind of cool
um i honestly like
i've always been okay with it but it's
not my like oh my god the [ __ ]
predator
yeah the predator like there was one
great movie
there which is the first one the second
one would be great if it didn't pretend
that we didn't know what the predator
was
because it's like it's danny glover and
something's killing all these jamaican
voodoo pasties
who could it be so [ __ ] the
predator is on the poster i know why i'm
here
it's the predator we've all seen it man
yeah there's no mystery here
um and then it gets it goes up its own
ass after that
um but yeah it's one of those like
characters cool somebody do a cool thing
with
it so i'm hoping that that team of folks
can do a cool thing with it
have you been watching animaniacs we're
looking down
no did you see any took a peek at it and
apparently twitter blowing up about
uh there's an episode that makes a
johnny depp
joke that they felt was a little too
current
or whatever um and went after it pretty
hardcore
and i assumed that that would have been
hbo max people are going after because
animaniacs of course
you know they live in the warner
brothers water tower they do
but it's not it's on hulu i mean that's
not the point of the story the point of
the story is
outraged about the johnny jeff jokes on
in that uh
episode of adamantium but why is that on
hulu and not on
on hbo max you think that is a damn fine
question and i
something that they started building
long before hbo max
coalesced or something it probably was
you know
and and also hbo max and warner brothers
and
hbo large you know it's still unclear
the different
differentiation between the two but yeah
they have stuff kind of all over the
place like sandman is gonna be on
netflix
and not on hbo max because they
they just they made that deal for that
you're right
and it makes sense man that makes sense
though that uh i mean
[ __ ] who else but netflix has that
kind of money i guess they all got that
kind of money now hbo max
making very expensive things everybody
making very expensive things
they're all spending all kinds of money
for the hope of
network subscribers um
what uh somebody pointed out in chat
that um
the uh um end of predator 2
was pretty [ __ ] metal because you saw
all the artifacts from all the times
that the predator had come here
from the past and i remember that and i
was like oh yeah that was kind of cool
yeah and then that was also the first
time that on that wall of trophies you
saw an
alien skull yeah and it was like what
these are the same universe oh my god
and then they did it in comics and then
they did it in the movie yeah alien v
predator led predator 2 um
what else we got um lord and miller
um you know those fellas phil lord chris
miller who have done
yesterday watched into the spider verse
which is so
[ __ ] amazing still holds up so great
um you know they're they're live
live-action debut i believe is directors
was 21 jump street
and they've you know been very close i
think with
channing tatum to the point that now
they are going
to be remaking a mysterious yet to be
revealed
universal horror movie um
one is that um miller and lord and
channing tatum are making a universal
monster movie
all right well we know it ain't wolf man
because that's what
ryan uh gosling's doing
right um we know it ain't the [ __ ]
creature from the black lagoon because
why would you take somebody like
channing tatum and cover him in rubber
correct does seem like a dracula type to
me
who good the picture's up um
he i mean i i guess if you go hard you
could kind of frankenstein's monster him
but
maybe in the invisible man well i mean i
think
that they are they're using the
blumhouse invisible man
i think is a bit of a model which is
this was a universal horror movie we've
updated it we've refashioned it we've
we've you know sort of post-modernized
it what else can we do that feels
like this and if i had to guess
i'm looking at the picture of the
universal monsters and i'm like
go ahead what do you guess because i
can't think um my guess is you could do
a movie
about about the price of beauty
and make that also a frankenstein movie
that somebody you know manages to bring
somebody back from the dead or
reassemble a thing or make the perfect
man
out of pieces of other dead bodies would
so would he be the monster or would he
be
i mean if you're looking for the most
beautiful man in the world he he has
been the sexiest man alive before
so making him the monster here's a hot
take from the chat
room oh oh ab oh zero zero rabbit rabbit
zero i don't know how to pronounce it
i said chevy chase is my invisible man
did you ever see
memoirs of an invisible man by john
carpenter what's your favorite invisible
man movie
um [ __ ] i mean part of me wants to go
the paul verhoeven kevin bacon one that
was the creepy
one that was the creepiest one that's
it's super rapey
um but it also does that thing where it
imagines the worst impulses of a person
given power
and and that's kind of probably where
that story goes
yeah it is kind of a monster movie i i
like the one they just did recently i
thought it was awesome
yeah it's really strong and so if if
they're looking to
you know kind of reimagine what those
things could be
and i don't know if they're going to
touch the mummy any time within a decade
of the tom cruise mummy
um which is a shame because that's i
mean and if i was them i'd [ __ ] make
a mummy with brendan frazier again
watch how fast it makes cash like
everyone's into nostalgia right now man
they'd be like oh my god i [ __ ] i
want to see that
um all right what else we got um
somebody said dorian gray maybe he's
playing dorian gray but i don't think
that's a universal monster
no no i don't think so either and i
think that they also
might be steering clear of creatures of
the black lagoon given that shape of
water
ultimately was guillermo's creature of
the black lagoon movie
and uh like how many of these do we need
no point in doing that because it's just
been
[ __ ] done yeah and done loudly
and too great reception um remember we
talked
god must have been three four months ago
maybe
longer i don't know about the last of us
video game
yeah how uh and how craig mason he
of of ye old chernobyl fame um
was working with the creator of that
video game to adapt it for hbo
it just got a series order at hbo so
that is a show that is coming that is a
show that that is a hundred percent on
the way
and it wasn't before it was just
somebody like ordering a script and now
they're saying it's
right it was like we want to make a show
and now it's we're making a show
any casting no casting yet um
the thing that that that interests me
and we'll also talk about it with the
next story
is what the difference is between hbo
and hbo max
when it comes to warner brothers
deciding to commission a tv show
and i don't have the answer to it but
clearly there is a difference
there is some semblance of one of these
is shinier than the other
one of these you know while one might
have the most
heat at the moment hbo max seems to be
the the thing that warner media is most
invested in at the time
but hbo is still where all of the kind
of like prestige shiny [ __ ]
ends up and so how they they decide
that last of us is going to hbo and who
pays for what
so does it pays for what and versus you
know
the next show which is dmz based on the
brian wood comic book that ava duvernay
directed the pilot of
um is going to hbo max and this is about
like new york after a war or something
yeah new york after a second american
civil war
and how parts of manhattan are
ultimately like demilitarized zones that
that don't adhere to either
the new republic or the old republic
it's just this in-between zone
that people have to find a way to live
that people have to find a way to
survive
and it follows a journalist i think
um it's been a decade since i read it
but um but but yeah and
rosario dawson we're being reminded that
we had uh
ashley johnson uh on the show not too
long ago who played
who does the voice of yeah in that game
um yes i i think we all remember that um
thank you for reminding us but uh she's
not being
they'd be cast in the show she'd be too
old to play that part right yeah i mean
that part
cameo or something like that yeah i mean
in the first game ellie is like
15 i think 15 or 16 years old ashley
johnson looks young but i don't know if
she could pull off 15.
yeah that's that's that's a tough pull
um
but yeah so dmz and also dmz is a
limited series
and not a full-on series i think i think
it's it's four episodes
but they're gonna spend a billion
dollars on it you know ava's directing
the pilot i'm not sure if she's gonna
keep on directing it the cast is rosario
dawson and benjamin bratt
and it's for what over dst
yeah yeah um so yeah it's it's a big
priority for them
but it's also i just don't understand
the the difference between the two and
how the decision making decides what
goes in one pile and what goes in the
other all i know is they ain't giving us
any money
yeah they are not so far yeah
fingers crossed sweet hbo max money
uh john bartley says hey kevin and mark
any advice for somebody who's about to
quit
his real job he says and follow his
filmmaking dreams you did something like
that and you're now getting rewarded
like crazy you were a guy that
worked in a different medium altogether
and then one day you were like you know
what
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna burn my
boats and stay in the new world
um i i would suggest to you uh kind sir
that you don't quit your job till you
have a new job
um and i think it all depends on what it
is you want to be doing
like i i was lucky enough to want to be
a writer which is a thing that i could
do in my spare time
um that required very little financial
uh investment
to do um and i did not quit
my day job until i had another job
immediately lined up because i have a
family to feed and
mortgages to pay and all of the above
so you know but if you want to like
carve boats for a living and that's a
thing you need to go to [ __ ] nova
scotia to do
then okay man like chase your bliss i
hope it works out for you but be as
be as mindful and as cautious as you can
be
um while also still being ready to take
a plunge
um wise advice uh mine made clerks it
worked for me
yeah i didn't i didn't make a choice but
mine was like uh
you know like i was young and like oh my
god
i'm sure this will work out and god
willing it did uh
though and then i i kind of just
kept my foot in the door and stuff but
mark's advice incredibly sound
well done what else do we want quit a
job
in this economy says james career yeah i
know think about
before you quit a real job and then
somebody pointed out directing is a real
job but i'm like
i mean i've done it a few times
[Laughter]
real easy it's real all right real easy
yeah yeah and also the math gets way
more complicated the older you get
um when you're young and in your 20s and
you want to make giant career decisions
like all right it's just you
that you're worrying about you know fine
[ __ ] it let's do it we'll we'll roll the
dice
when you get older there tends to be
more numbers in your math equation that
you've got to worry about
so do those numbers do that math and
then make your choice
the punisher thomas jane one point i was
shooting an
interview with him about uh 10 years ago
this
this fall 10 years ago and um
he looked down the barrel of the lens
because the question was
uh what advice would you give young
hollywood
on how to make it you look down the bear